[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a la chance d'organiser
au proto 204 à 4o qui est un concours de
programmation dont le thème est comment
on va détecter les mouvements au sein
d'une cité intelligente comme le plateau
de sacrée et donc ça va durer sur deux
jours ici on va accueillir et des
étudiants de l'hygiène stm et le grand
public des hackers n'importe qui peut
venir pour proposer une solution la base
de programmation pour résoudre ce
challenge il travaille sur le thème des
objets connectés
donc comment on peut faire dans une
ville intelligente pour détecter du
mouvement pour répondre à des
problématiques autour ce sujet là avec
des objets connectés
typiquement les étudiants qui nous
accompagne aujourd'hui ont à leur
disposition des kits de développement
des caméras et des librairies de
programmation qui leur permettre de
détecter un mouvement
ce qui nous intéresse nous chez nokia au
travers ce projet c'est de voir comment
on peut demain améliorer le plateau de
saclay avec un réseau une infrastructure
une plateforme et des solutions
concrètes des objets connectés qui sont
capables de faire ça des exemples
d'applications pressante par exemple
c'est de détecter des personnes dans un
abribus pour optimiser le trajet des bus
et améliorer les phases de récupération
des personnes c'est de détecter les flux
des voitures pour optimiser le trafic ce
genre de choses on a mis à disposition
un certain nombre de ressources
également des mentors qui peuvent les
aider à avancer dans leurs projets à la
fin de la journée il y aura un pitch
dans lequel ils m'ont expliqué leur
projet et éventuellement montré un
prototype la journée de demain est
déviée au public
elle commence d'ailleurs dès ce soir où
les gens pourront venir commencé à coder
venir commencé à travailler sur leurs
idées et demain soir sera remis un prix
à la meilleure idée qui aura été
sélectionnés par un jury dont nous sont
partis
[Musique]